now to the united states where
independence day celebrations were
marred by a mass shooting which left six
people dead and 30 injured in the
chicago suburb of highland park a gunman
opened fire from a rooftop striking
crowds gathering for a fourth of july
parade
after hours of uncertainty police have
detained a 22 year old suspect
it was supposed to be a day of
celebration of fun with friends and
family
instead people had to run for their
lives
minutes earlier families with young
children had been gathering for the
parade
when gunshots suddenly rang out
panicked parents trying to protect their
children
i remember hearing shootings and going
like
all i thought about is just you know
getting my daughter to safety and i ran
with her
we went to the nearest mcdonald's
and
you know she lost her shoe along the way
my daughter and she was you know she was
scared he started shooting again
and we ran behind the building and i put
my my son in a dumpster
and
he sat there with his dog
and i went back to look for the rest of
my family it was just horrible
police say the shooter fired into the
crowd from a nearby rooftop with a
high-powered rifle
five people were killed at the scene
another victim died in hospital
dozens of people were injured among them
children
the attack comes just a month after two
mass shootings in texas in new york
it is devastating that a celebration of
america was ripped apart by our uniquely
american plague
a day dedicated to freedom has put into
stark relief
the one freedom we as a nation refuse to
uphold
the freedom of our fellow citizens to
live without the daily fear of gun
violence
the shooter managed to flee before
police stormed the rooftop
authorities issued a stay-at-home order
for residents in the area while a huge
manhunt got underway
meanwhile police announced they had
identified a 22 year old man as a person
of interest
he was arrested without incident and
taken into custody more than eight hours
after the shooting
a shooting that means that for some
families july 4th will no longer be
associated with celebration but with
terror and grief
for more now i'm joined by amber gilmore
a journalist in chicago amber uh a 22
year old suspect is in custody what more
can you tell us about how he was
apprehended and his identity
good morning from chicago terry we know
that the suspect
the shooter was arrested 6 30 p.m local
time in chicago by local authorities and
by the fbi we know that his name is
robert e crimo the third we know that
he's 22 years old he's a resident of the
highland park
area we know that another family member
of of cremo was also arrested
in the city of chicago a couple hours
after his arrest
do we have any idea what motivated the
shooter uh assuming it's the person
just trying to figure out what motivated
anyone to do to carry out an act like
this or is there any speculation about
that
um as of now there's been a several
press conferences and the motive is
still unclear we know that it's still an
active uh investigation from
the fbi from atf and also from the
highland park police we know that at
least 17 agents and agencies are been
helping or are helping with the
investigation with highland park
as of now there is no motive it's an
active investigation
and that's the latest that we have right
now
and tell us about the victims and we've
got multiple people dead multiple people
wounded in that attack
we know that a couple of maybe an hour
ago or so the uh highland park did
mention um that they have uh
giving resources counseling services for
the family that are being effective also
for the uh family members and victims we
know as of so far as six people have
been killed um 31 have been injured we
know that the agents are between eight
years old and 85 years old we know that
four of those are
amber thank you very much that was
journalist amber gilmore in chicago